Today's show is sponsored by audible.
Go to audible.com/Carlin.
That's audible.com/Carlin
or text Carlin two five zero zero five
zero zero.
To get started,
I've just heard the audio that you're
about to hear and this is my own
critique of the audio that you're about
to hear and it's a little redundant only
because I actually started off the
program with a little bit of that sort
of talk to.
So I apologize for the redundancy.
Um,
but I'm going to call this episode.
I'm going to throw a nightmare somehow
because it sounds like a nightmare and I
don't just mean because of the material
which is nightmarish.
Nothing new about that of course on what
we do,
but almost my recounting of it is like
that.
Like you woke up in the middle of the
night screaming and the next morning and
your spouse says to you,
what the heck was that all about?
And you try to recount what happened to
you in your nightmare.
And it always sounds like a bunch of
disjointed flashing images.
Um,
you know,
we always like to try to put a little
artistic touch,
your little flare here or there with the
big hardcore history shows and I feel
like that's what's missing in the audio
that you're going to hear now.
It sounds like a nightmare.
It sounds like I'm just telling you the
highlights or worst moments or the
things that freaked me out the most or
whatever is sticking in my memory after
going back to sleep in the middle of the
night.
But for some of you especially,
I think you know,
those of you who already know some of
this or all of this story,
it will remind you once again that you
know,
if I'm recounting a nightmarish sort of
story to you,
I mean think about how many people
actually woke up in the night for many,
many,
many decades after this event with this
exact same nightmare.
And it's pretty safe to say that unlike
me who wasn't there,
the people who were there would probably
be unable to tell anyone else who wasn't
there.
You know,
what they were seeing in their dreams.
So apologies for the lack of artistic
flair and what you're going to hear now,
but I'm in welcome to a nightmare of the
Indianapolis.
It's hardcore history.
I've tried to think about what the
difference between one of these hardcore
history addendums and one of the larger
hardcore history shows is.
I mean,
what's the difference between the two of
them besides obviously that we're doing
some interviews,
but I thought,
you know,
there's a whole bunch of great stories
out there and I write them down.
You know,
whenever I think of when I put it in a
book so that some day when I don't have
enough ideas,
there's a bunch already down.
I know a lot of you do this too and a
bunch of these ideas are not worth a
whole history show or you can't do a
whole history show.
I mean,
I'd love to do something and have wanted
to do something for a long time on the
ancient Egyptian neighbor known as
coolish cushite,
but there is no primary source material.
I mean,
it's one of those things where you just
can't hang a whole show on what you have
to work with.
There's a lot of stories like that.
The one today is like that.
I mean there is actually enough material
to do a whole big four hour thing on
this subject,
but it would get repetitive and it would
get repetitive in a way that makes the
first world war program we did with
risk.
Pretty repetitive in terms of,
you know,
ongoing horror.
It would make that seem a little tame
because at a certain point in this story
there's nothing but that and it's
psychological torture after a certain
amount of time and so it's hard to not
get gratuitous or it's hard to not just
get redundant at a certain point.
You want to be able to say to the
audience and there's just more of that
and you know what that's like.
I thought about talking about this
because I caught really the tail end the
other night of a movie that's
underrated.
Although when I went online to do some
more modern research on it,
I was surprised to find that it is
considered kind of an artistic classic
now.
It's one of Steven Spielberg's really
early movies.
It's jaws think it came out in 1975.
I was 10 and I can tell you that it was
a huge event and sort of an unexpected
when there'd been a novel that had done
pretty well,
but the novel was very different than
the movie and the movie as all I think
really great films do has a number of
really fine actors in it and you give
those people a of really fine script and
I guess there was a significant amount
of improvisation from time to time that
made it into the final version that the
actors did.
But you remember who was in that
immediate Roy Scheider who was great.
You had Richard Dreyfus who is still
great and my God,
you had Robert Shaw who was unbelievable
in the.
In that role,
I mean among others,
and you get the three of them at certain
points in the story and they're just in
the cabin.
I mean,
there's no scenery,
there's no movement,
really have the cameras.
It's just those three actors working to
find script and at one point Robert Shaw
goes into a monologue and it's
incredible from a,
from an appreciating the craft
standpoint.
Those of you who remember though,
the monologue it has to do with the
character that Robert Shaw,
his playing and his past.
He's playing sort of an old sea dog kind
of fishermen who is going to catch this
shark and he knows a lot about sharks
and he goes into the background and it
turns out he was on the USS Indianapolis
and those of you who know that story,
no,
how that's connected to sharks.
And so I'm watching this.
I'm the tail end.
Like I said,
Josie and the night I just thought,
you know,
the Indianapolis is an amazing story and
it typifies were sort of.
Some of my interests tend to lean,
as you all know.
I always like to say maybe it's a nice
way of saying that I'm into the extremes
of the human experience,
but some people think I'm just into war
and violence and you know,
it's funny.
Sometimes I'll read accounts from like
100 years ago.
There's a famous one from a German
general named von Moltke where he talks
about sort of the the reasons you
wouldn't want to go too long between
wars because it brings out something in
the human character and he's not talking
about the low level side.
You know,
the,
the killing of your fellow man and
butchery.
He's talking about sort of the higher
side of the human experience and it's
weird to think about that.
See,
I don't agree with him about that.
I'm not going there,
but the story of the Indianapolis is a
perfect example of something where it
only happens because of war,
but what happens after the sinking of
the ship,
the famous sinking of the ship is one of
these tales were.
I mean you just.
It sends tears down your face and not
just because of the human suffering,
but because of the human reaction to the
suffering,
right?
That it was kind of those higher
qualities that von Moltke was sort of
referring to when you see people under
amazing amounts of physical and
psychological pressure with fellow human
beings and how they act in situations
that are far more stressful than what
one could be expected to reasonably
handle.
Yeah.
The Indianapolis combines a number of
things which would make my top 10 list
of worst nightmares,
wrap them all into one wonderful
package.
If you are a fan of disaster movies,
not to compare this to a disaster movie,
no offense,
um,
family members of Indianapolis
survivors' or not survivors,
but I mean,
thank you.
My mom was in a movie once that was a
knock,
a knock off of the towering inferno.
So build a burning building.
That's a disaster movie.
You hang a whole movie on that and you
have something like the Poseidon
Adventure or titanic,
which is a disaster movie of a ship
sinking at sea.
Hang a whole movie on that.
There are,
I mean each,
each segment and phase in the
Indianapolis story is one of those
disaster films and by the time the
stories over and is the story ever
really over,
um,
you know,
these people,
it's like these people went from the
towering inferno,
hopped on board the titanic.
I mean it just one thing after another
and I don't mean to make light of it
because when you read the accounts of
what these people went through and then
you sort of magnify it because what they
went through is not that uncommon in
human history that they're not like
these real outliers.
It's uncommon for you and me to have
gone through it.
But how many mariners over the waves
over the era's have had their ship sink
and gone through the terrible things
that,
that involves.
And then had to deal with some of the
subsidiary things that all of the people
who went in the water with the
Indianapolis had to deal with.
So in a funny way,
this is a kind of common,
uncommon human experience,
if you will.
All but the Indianapolis,
his story is they're just.
It's got its own twists.
In this case,
if you don't know it,
let me fill you in for a minute and I
don't know how well this is going to
work in short form because you know
that's not my normal genre,
but the Indianapolis is famously known.
It's a USS Portland class cruiser.
Heavy cruiser.
Heavy cruisers generally mean,
you know,
bigger,
more armor,
a bigger gun.
So in the United States navy in the
Second World War,
if it had six inch guns,
it was probably a light cruiser.
If it had eight inch guns,
it was probably a heavy cruiser,
about 10,000
tons,
big ship home between 600 and 700 feet
long.
And in this case the Indianapolis is
famous because it delivered some of the
key components to an island in the
Pacific that would be put together and
made into the first atomic bomb.
But because of that it was a secret
mission and people weren't really in the
know about the comings and the goings of
the Indianapolis perhaps as well as they
should have been aware of it.
And this kind of plays into the story in
a pretty big way because after
delivering the components to the island
of Tinian,
this Indianapolis Portland class heavy
cruiser goes off on its merry way kind
of towards the Philippines,
I think it was.
And in the night gets torpedoed by a
Japanese submarine.
Now this is in 1945,
I think it's July.
So it's,
you know,
we are not that far from the end of the
war at all.
I mean,
as we said,
they're kind of putting the parts
together for the Hiroshima bomb.
So not that far away from the end of the
war.
But now you get to the first level of
this disaster that these Indianapolis
folks have to deal with,
imagined being asleep in your bunk at
night on a ship and to torpedo,
slam into it.
One slammed into the bow at the front of
the ship,
one slam,
sort of mid ships,
but a little forward,
um,
survivors' accounts.
And by the way,
you want to read a good book on this.
Let me just break into this for a
minute.
I really loved in harm's way by Doug
Stanton,
although there are several books on the
Indianapolis.
I'm going to quote a couple of pieces
from Stanton's book,
but if you think the story is
interesting and you want to get the real
feel for it,
he does a great job,
I think.
But Stanton talks about,
you know,
when the two torpedoes hit,
he,
he's talking to a survivor that was
loaded than the front of the ship and he
was asleep in his bunk.
And one of these,
uh,
you know,
sort of ship rooms that they have that
you probably have six,
eight,
10 guys in the bunks are stacked against
the wall.
And when the torpedoes hit,
the survivor says the lights go out and
all the bunks fall and everybody's in a
pile of people and some have broken arms
and ribs.
And everybody of course woken up from a
deep sleep.
You're totally confused.
And with the lights out,
it's extra bad.
So immediately this ship starts having
problems and so the crew starts doing
the typical things you do to try to
prevent the ship from sinking.
And one of the things you do is you
start walling off the compartments that
are damaged and flooding
dogging things down is the way a stanton
has the navy guys describing it in the
book.
But the problem with that is if you're
cutting off compartments that are
flooding,
what do you do with the people that are
still in the flooding compartments?
Right?
So the first thing that just horrifies
you in this story of the Indianapolis
going down at night in the tropical
waters,
sort of east of the Philippines,
is that you have these sailors who have
to cut their own ship mates off in
flooding compartments.
And Stan says,
you can hear him scream,
you know,
don't,
don't leave us here.
I mean,
what do you.
But what are you supposed to do?
So right there you get in what to talk
human experiences that are extreme and
that are already larger than most of us
will ever face in the first five minutes
of this disaster.
There are guys dealing with things that
are going to haunt their memories the
rest of their lives.
And the end,
the affair is hardly started.
You know,
when you talk about the human capacity
for endurance survival and not just
survival through the event,
but then to be able to live with it,
you know,
afterwards,
and by the way,
the guy who was the captain of the
Indianapolis made it about 20 years,
um,
afterwards he'll survive the whole
thing,
but he'll kill himself.
Still Getting Christmas cards from
people who say,
and I'm quoting one here,
merry Christmas.
Our family's holiday would be a lot
merrier if you hadn't killed my son,
stent.
And says that the captain,
a guy named mcvay would keep all of
these letters and put them,
you know,
with a ribbon around them and keep them
in his desk,
blaming himself always for what happened
on that dark night.
But on this ship,
these people that survive will talk
about seeing him,
you know,
running around this sinking ship as it
starts to take on water.
And by the way,
they have 12 minutes between the time
the torpedo strike until the time it
goes down.
And once again,
the idea of having a between 600 and 700
foot long,
10,000
ton ship begin to disintegrate out from
under you and go under water as the
waves begin rolling people off the deck
is crazy also.
So now right away we're like the second
stage.
So you had to cut your semen off and dog
down into compartments and consign them
to certain depths of the rest of the
ship might survive.
Now you're dealing with the mental image
of this ship starting to go down by the
bow that's in the front and the stern
starts to slowly rise out of the.
I mean the ship is going perpendicular
and people are dropping off and stanton
describe survivors saying people will
jump off and hit the rudders.
People will jump off and hit the
propellors that are still spinning and
be launched off into space.
Once again,
how do you even in 12 minutes or less
really pro process all this and it's
dark and people are freaking out.
I mean this is like a giant accident
scene right away.
There's like between 11 and 1200 guys on
the ship and more than 300 are going to
die in the first 12 minutes,
and so you're watching all this
happening and many of these people now
are grievously wounded.
Stanton,
I'm one of the main survivors he talks
about in this thing.
I mean the first thing he hears when he
recovers from hearing the torpedo hits
is somebody screaming in the compartment
next door and he runs over there,
realizes it's his friend,
the dentist,
but he can't open the door because the
whole thing's on fire and he just has to
let him burn to death in the first two
minutes and then he burns his hand
because the ship itself is turning red
hot.
He puts his hands on the deck or on a
rail boom and he's got burned hands
and then there's the ship starts to go
kind of perpendicular.
He tells the story about they have a
bunch of wounded people,
I guess in the Sick Bay,
but they're on cots and they're tied to
their beds and whatnot and he says they
just all slide right into the sea and
he's sitting there watching this happen.
Slack,
jawed.
I read a book a while back and it's
about how people react in disasters,
trying to remember what it was like if
the worst should occur or something like
that.
I think we talked about at once.
Um,
but,
but it's by one of these experts who
studies these things and one of the
things that they said is in situations
like this,
right?
Plane crashes,
shipwrecks or whatnot.
Most people are like stunned into
numbness.
They don't do anything right.
In some of these bad plane crashes,
everybody could have gotten out,
but they sat there and burned to death,
you know,
on the tarmac.
That's shocking.
But that's what you would expect to
happen on a ship like this.
And yet maybe it's the military
training.
Who knows?
Maybe it's the thank.
You have officers barking out orders,
but you're not seeing a ton of that.
You are seeing people jumping in the
water as fast as they can go because
they're all afraid of the same thing.
When a big ship goes down,
it sucks stuffed down with it.
A lot of the time it creates a vacuum
that that can drowned swimmers who are
anywhere nearby so everyone knows that
the ship's going down.
You've got to get as far away from it as
possible.
It's like you know when you get into an
auto wreck and you're worried that the
gasoline is leaking in,
the car is going to catch on fire.
You want to get far away from it.
Well,
when the ship goes down,
it's going to suck everything down with
it.
In several of the survivors,
once again,
imagine this,
one of them talks about having it feel
as though somebody was yanking his foot
in his shoe came off and all of a sudden
with a life vest,
he went way under water to where his
ears are popping in.
His eyes feel like they're going to pop
out of his head,
and then he said he got caught in a
giant air bubble that escaped from the
sinking ship and it goes,
pops up and shoots him up.
He said three feet into the air before
we came down again in an absolutely
pitch black ocean covered as far as the
eye could see.
It could see in the dark with a two inch
thick molasses like consistency,
oil spill from the ship that is burning
the eyes and coding all of these men.
And if you ever look at photographs of
people being rescued from like their
shipping torpedoed when maybe they were
in the merchant marine,
maybe they were on a destroyer,
but you can kind of see there's some
great a life magazine ones I recall.
And when they come on board,
they're covered in oil and that's what
these people are instantly covered in.
And what's worse is that oil can catch
on fire and the surface of the ocean can
burn.
That happened.
If you look at,
um,
movie footage,
you can see that happen to Pearl Harbor.
You know the ocean caught on fire in
places,
so at this point what you have is the
equivalent of like the titanic sinking
where the Lusitania is torpedoing big
ship going down in the middle of the
ocean.
Now,
difference between both the titanic and
the Lusitania,
though,
if I can boil it down to one thing is
the temperature.
When the titanic sank,
you had an iceberg,
so it's cold.
The Lusitania went down sort of over by
Ireland.
I believe I'm cold water.
You're not going to have people
surviving a long time in the water.
Now,
if you're trying to rescue them
actively,
this is a nightmarish situation,
right?
You've got to get to the people before
they get hypothermia and they die in the
water.
On the other hand,
if you're going to die anyway in the
water,
in the Pacific,
in the very tropical warm regions,
you might wish it had come as quickly as
cold water because when the water is
warm as it is,
sometimes slightly over 80 degrees,
you can stay on the water a long time.
Good thing if you're trying to be
rescued,
bad things.
If there's other things in the water you
know besides you that you need to worry
about,
also bad if you don't have any fresh
water,
which they don't,
and all of a sudden,
I think 300 or so men perished right
away.
Nine hundred or so men are in the water
and you begin.
Now,
the other part of the nightmarish thing,
um,
I don't know how many of you have been
in the ocean at night in the water,
in the ocean at night.
There's something calm and beautiful
about it.
Isn't there?
But there's something,
a little freaky about it too.
First of all,
you have no idea what's going on
underneath you if you're in the deep
areas,
right?
I mean there's a whole world of ocean
underneath you.
What's more is if there is no moon out,
it can get pitch black and you can't see
anything.
So now when we talk about personal
things that would bother us.
We're getting into my own personal
nightmares a little bit here because you
throw me out in the middle of the ocean
in pitch black darkness.
That is.
So I'm already going to have some
psychological problems,
I think,
and I do think that this is why these
stories fascinate me because these
figures in the story because of things
like war are cast into situations that
are well unimaginable.
And if they just gave up,
we would totally understand the fact
that they don't is,
you know,
the old,
it's a cliche,
but it's the triumph of the human
species.
Right?
And let's be honest,
a bunch of people do give up in this
story and you can totally sympathize
with them too,
when you hear what they've gone through.
So the story continues and you begin to
find,
you know,
the men,
as the light of day breaks out in
groups,
they're all in clusters spread out over
a great distance,
you know,
calling to each other,
trying to find each other,
trying to sort of swim to each other as
best they can.
The horrible part of the story now,
when they're in the water though,
is a lot of people have horrible
injuries.
You didn't have a bunch of healthy,
you know,
ready to go.
Lifeguard type people,
jump in the water,
you had a bunch of shipwreck survivors,
people,
you know,
one guy in the story,
um,
and once again,
I always try to remember that the people
who were with these people who survived
carried these memories with them
forever.
But one guy in this story,
I'm a friend of one of the people he
keeps quoting in the book,
Stanton has his eyes completely burned
out and he's going to die,
but it's going to take him time,
but nobody wants to leave him again.
You see these higher qualities come to
the fore where,
I mean,
nobody might survive this,
but we're going to take a guy who's
certainly not going to survive it and
expand,
you know,
important energy that could be spent on
living people that are,
you know,
could go either way.
But that's,
that's the higher human qualities,
right?
And so he talks about this guy
eventually saying,
I'm not going to make it.
I want,
here's what I want you to tell my wife,
you know,
and all these kinds of things.
And it's wrenching.
Once again,
I can't help but think that if the
person,
I think he's a doctor who's hearing this
man with the burnout,
I'll tell him,
you know,
here's what I want you to tell my wife.
If he's in no danger at all,
he's going to take that memory to the
grave with him,
right?
Probably going to drink a lot more
whiskey than he otherwise would have
drank in his life because that is such a
emotionally impacting moment,
but he himself is about to go through
this harrowing experience and it's going
to be one hammer blow to the psyche of
these people after another.
You have a lot of wounded people in the
water,
bleeding,
lot of burns,
and as you all know,
Burns are particularly nasty and
horrible and not enough life jackets,
people floating on flotsam and Jetsam.
The Guy I just mentioned who had to
here,
you know what the dying sailor wanted,
his wife told was named Dr Haynes and
he's quoted by Stanton in the book and
this incident is particularly
highlighted.
And by the way,
um,
people are vomiting because they've
ingested salt water and fuel oil.
Stanton writes,
quote,
a few boys were vomiting violently that
they
were actually doing somersaults in the
water trying to keep calm.
Haynes called out here,
right here,
where's the six sailor,
and then he moved into the throng,
about a dozen sailors were holding a
body aloft and amazing feat of strength
considering that they were all treading
water furiously to stay afloat beneath
the added weight,
the man in question was in terrible
shape.
Stanton writes,
his eyes had been burned away.
The flesh on his hands was gone,
and what remained were bare tendons.
The boy held him up in an effort to keep
these wounds out of the stinging bath of
Saltwater Haynes.
Recognize the man as his good friend in
liberty,
buddy gunnery officer Stanley Lipski.
Miraculously Lipski had made his way
blind from the quarter deck off the ship
and into the water.
Haynes knew that Lipsky's pain must be
intolerable.
He himself could barely look at his old
friend who was moaning softly.
Stanley he knew was one tough bird.
Hanes also understood that he didn't
have long to live reluctantly.
He turned away
to those who could actually help end
quote,
and yet that guy with the burned out
eyes will make it onto a life raft and
eventually tell that same doctor,
you know,
what he wants his wife to no last words
and you know,
get married again after me and all that.
Now I should point out that at this
point in the story,
you know,
it could be a war story from many
theaters,
many different kinds of conflicts,
over many different arrows.
The part though that is about to happen
now,
the part that inspired me to talk about
this perhaps tapping into,
you know,
your own secret nightmares is a little
bit different and no doubt it happened
many times in history,
not recorded on anyone's parchment or
know logs anywhere,
but this happened in close enough to
modern times that we have many,
many,
many gruesome memories written down by
survivors of what it was like to go down
in the middle of the ocean with sharks
everywhere.
Have you ever seen the drone footage?
Some of it came out recently.
Lee was showing,
I think it was the Florida coast from a
drone above,
I don't want to say 500 feet,
a thousand feet above just the
coastline,
so it's basically taking pictures 100
yards off shore and it appears to be
schools of fish.
That's what it looks like if you're not
paying close attention.
So you know,
lots of fish.
It's not,
you know,
fish in the general term,
I guess it's officially still fish,
but they're sharks and I guess they.
Maybe we're migrating,
but the first thing you notice if you're
paying attention to you watch it over
and over and over again.
Not that I'm obsessed with it or
anything like that is that most of these
sharks I was reading in the photograph
or in the drone footage are in the four
to six feet range,
kind of a fully grown,
a decent size shark from one of these
particular breeds of shark.
But you can instantly tell those average
size ones,
you know,
every now and then there are big,
big,
big ones.
I mean you don't even know what they
are.
Eighteen feet maybe.
I mean,
you look at them and there you go.
That's three times as long as the other
one.
Imagine being,
you know,
just your paragliding one day off the
Florida coast and you just splashed down
right in the middle of that.
Now there's no guarantee that anything
will happen to you,
right?
They may just all scatter and
frightened.
Leave you totally alone,
but they might not.
Now,
what if you're bleeding at the same time
that's going to make any difference or
wounded.
What if you're there for a long time and
you don't go away?
I mean,
it's one thing to say I crashed,
landed off the coast of Florida into a
school of sharks and I swam to the shore
and I made it out.
Morocco stay alive.
You have,
but what have you stayed there for four
days.
Hm?
Is that a nightmare?
It's a nightmare.
And the daytime.
What happens when you turn out the
lights on that and what happens when the
sharks start attacking?
Not You,
but people within hearing distance of
you.
The nightmare of the Indianapolis and
the key part of the monologue that
Robert Shaw gives us,
the quint character in jaws is what the
moment when the sharks started attacking
the hundreds of men in the water is like
they can see them underneath them.
I mean,
this is what's so freaky,
is that this water is apparently clear
to like 40 or 50 feet.
You know,
you're in the tropics.
It's a gorgeous color.
As a matter of fact,
it's so bright when the sun starts
hitting the water that,
that it's blinding people and it's over
100 degrees in the daytime.
So they're frying the parts that are
above the water.
If these people have life vests,
a bunch of the people who are floating
in the water with life vests will lose
everything underneath the water to the
sharks.
And there are multiple accounts of
people you know,
tapping a buddy who appears to be
sleeping in his life,
vest on the water's surface and having,
you know,
by the way,
the Quintin jaws actually talks about
this too.
And having them turn over like,
uh,
like,
like you know,
bob,
if you will turn over and there's
nothing below the waist,
you can see the sharks below you.
Some of these sailors that a stanton
talks about say that they would see some
of the same sharks and recognize them so
often that they gave them names.
Once Taylor gave a tiger shark of huge
tiger shark,
the name Oscar,
and eventually another stapler took a
two inch pen knife,
which is,
you know,
nothing and tried to stab at one of
these things.
Some of these sailors were on a raft
where it was a,
the raft was disintegrating over time
and it had a sort of a lattice floor,
if you will.
And there was a little hole developing
in the floor.
And these big sharks would come up and
stick their snouts right through.
I mean,
again,
you saw this in jars with jaws,
with the mechanical structure.
Stick their nose right through and try
to get ahold of something.
The sailors started kicking it in the
face to me being in
the ocean in the middle of the night,
you know,
no land anywhere,
no ships anywhere,
no birds,
no planes and sharks all around hundreds
of them.
To me,
that is the most terrifying situation I
can think about and what I,
what I was going to do once as I was
going to do either a book or maybe a TV
series where the entire premise was
based around the worst place you can be
in the world on any given moment in
history dot January 27th,
1987 and Tunisia the worst place to be
in the world.
Um,
you know,
the battle of cannae in Italy,
worst place to be,
to work.
This is the worst place to be in the
world.
To me on that date,
and maybe any date,
it takes a lot of the things that are
the most nasty things I can think of.
Packages them together in one horrible
sort of event,
and then put these people in this
psychological challenge where day after
day they're in the water because nobody
knows they're gone this mission.
So secret delivering the components for
the bomb meant that they were,
it wasn't like they were totally off the
radar when you read the reports,
it was quite a scandal after the war
because the Indianapolis going down will
be the worst disaster in US Navy
history.
But there were several sort of,
let's just call them variables maybe.
I mean,
first of all,
war,
okay?
Variable number one.
But these ships should have been noticed
when they were missing.
They were the number of little things
that happened.
And you can see this,
I mean the Pearl Harbor attacks,
another one where,
a little variable here,
if that doesn't happen,
this doesn't happen.
Um,
I don't want to call it okay,
but you can kind of see how it happened.
And yet what it meant was instead of
being rescued within a reasonable period
of time,
these people are going to be out there
for day after day after day.
They have no water.
And eventually think about the
psychological torture that comes from
being absolutely able to see almost
nothing but water.
But you will go crazy and then die if
you start drinking the water around you.
Right?
Again,
it's another kind of disaster movie.
It's being stuck in the desert with
water all around you,
but it's essentially poisonous.
Right.
And there will come a time in the story
where I'm.
And it's funny because it will spread
from one man to another where people
will just start drinking the salt water
and knowingly die or be so crazed from
Thursday they don't care.
One thing I found particularly
fascinating about the shark aspect that
stands and explains in his book was the
idea that most of these sailors probably
did not have a very clear conception of
sharks the way we do.
I mean jaws was the big,
you know,
sort of before and after moment on that.
But we've been fascinated with sharks
ever since.
He points out that it was kind of the
stuff of legends back in this era and
the idea of confronting one had not been
really talked about very often.
And what's more,
he says,
standard says that the navy kind of
downplayed the danger because it wasn't
good for morale to talk about.
Yeah,
you could run into an 18 foot tiger
shark out there and they'll eat
anything.
Stanton says that initially the sharks
probably mostly went after the cadavers
in the water and that's why the real big
attacks did not start for awhile.
But then once they ran out of those to
go after that,
they started going after loan floaters
in the water as opposed to the ones that
had all gathered into groups.
And then they would go after the ones at
the outside of,
you know,
the circle of people floating in the
water stands and talks about,
you know,
the incident that we just mentioned,
the,
a sailor being cut in half below the
waist.
And then says that there was a sailor
who was on the verge of drowning that
was calling for help.
And so,
um,
well let me let stand and pick up the
story.
He writes,
quote,
at one point,
Bob Goss swam away from the group to aid
and exhausted sailor who was on the
verge of drowning.
The boy had clearly gone out of his head
at the site of the fish,
meaning the sharks circling below him.
He was waving his hands and calling for
help.
As Gauze paddled out,
he was intercepted immediately by a
large dorsal fin knifing towards him,
so he swam as fast as he could back to
the group.
The boy in distressed soon disappeared.
As the shark attacks multiplied,
stanton writes,
the ones optimistic boys were filled
with a sense of helplessness.
Jack Cassidy came face to face with a
tiger shark that had been bothering him
for so long that he had even given it a
name.
He called the beast Oscar.
He swung at it with a homemade knife and
buried the blade and inch deep in the
fish's tufts snout,
but Oscar swam away as if only annoyed.
Cassidy was furious.
He wanted to kill the shark,
but he was relieved to be left alone.
As the water flashed with twisting tails
and Dorsal fins,
the boys resolve to stay calm,
clamping their hands over their ears,
against the erupting screams,
but this resolve vanished when one of
the boys was dragged through the water
like a fisherman's.
Bob are tugged by a big catfish.
The victim clenched in the uplifted jaws
of a shark was pushed at waist level.
Through the surf screaming,
others disappeared quietly without a
trace.
Their life vests shooting back up to the
surface,
empty the straps in shreds.
As the excited sharks grew more
agitated,
the attacks intensified and ferocity
and quote.
There are many people who consider the
shark attacks over several days against
the Indianapolis survivors' to be the
worst incident of mass shark attacks in
history.
I would suggest that that's a hard one
to know.
Think of how many ships have perished
over the ages and well,
sharks are not a new phenomenon,
right?
Nonetheless,
we have very few accounts like that and
when you add up all the various elements
working on these people,
you just imagine that no one could last
long in that environment without losing
their mind.
And that's what begins to happen.
And we've seen this before,
right?
We did a,
we mentioned one guy when we were doing
blueprint for armageddon in the first
world war,
um,
that,
you know,
it's funny,
what sort of images make it into the
history books and what sort of memories,
right?
So you're in the first world war and
you're at Passchendaele and you see some
guy stuck in the mud and with all of the
things available to modern society at
that point in time,
they can't get him out and he's begging
people to help him and no one can do
anything.
So then they come back.
I forgot how many days later it was,
it might've only been one day,
but the guy whose memory this was as the
guy was still in the mud,
but he'd sunk all the way up to his head
and he was insane begging people to
shoot him.
We all have a limit,
right?
So it should not surprise any of us when
some of these people start losing their
minds in the water under these
conditions and you know,
you should also point out something
that's not always apparent when you're
young,
but as a 52 year old person now is
really apparent to me is how young most
of these people in this story are in my
mind,
their kids,
the captains in adult and some of these
officers are,
you know,
old enough to have young families and
whatnot.
Although these people were having
families at 18 years old back then,
a lot of them.
So a lot of them were parents.
But I mean,
when you read the biographies of these
people,
I mean,
you know,
they're kids to me and you're 18,
19,
20,
21 and you're having to deal with this.
I don't agree with von Moltke
[inaudible] line about,
you know,
that we need war because it preserves
these human qualities.
But you sure see them on display here,
don't you?
You wish you'd never have to see them on
display again,
but you can't help but marvel that
people can,
you know,
get through this and many of them don't.
I mean stanton tell story after story
about people that consciously decide to
give up that it's eaten.
Yeah,
I mean even talking about it with other
people who are stuck in the water,
that it's easy to do.
All you have to do.
He says his swim away from the group and
you will get hit by a shark within 100
yards.
People will drink the seawater knowing
it will kill them.
Doug Stanton writes,
quote those with broken arms and legs
and backs had gone into shock and died.
Others had succumbed to massive bleeding
or head wounds that suspended them in
another world.
Still.
Others simply drowned because they were
too exhausted to keep swimming.
They'd been afloat now without food,
water,
shelter,
or sleep for over 40 hours.
Of the 1,196
crew members who'd set sail from Guam
three days earlier,
probably no more than 600 were still
alive in the previous 24 hours alone.
At least 200 had likely slip beneath the
waves or have been victims of shark
attack.
Since the sinking he writes,
each boy had been floating through the
hours asking himself the same hard
question.
Will I live or do I quit and it's
Tuesday unfolded some of the starved
bleeding and delirious man began to form
their answers for those who gave up
death now seem to matter of destiny.
They started committing suicide.
Those still lucid enough,
looked on in disbelief.
He writes,
as their former shipmates calmly untied
their life vests,
took a single stroke forward and sank
without a word.
Others suddenly turned from the group
and started swimming,
waiting for a shark to hit,
and then looked up and terrified.
Satisfaction.
When it did,
others simply fell face forward and
refuse to rise.
A boy would swim over to his buddy,
lift his head by the hair from the water
and begin screaming for him to come to
his senses.
Often he refused and continued to
quietly drowned himself and quote no.
We should point out that there are
people in every navy and the Second
World War that saw actual combat that
had incidents like that and there were
quite a few people in the merchant
marine and the various civilian versions
that you know,
kept the supplies,
you know,
coming across the water and handling the
logistics that would have their ships
torpedoed,
who would go through similar things.
There's something perversely nasty about
having the water be warm enough to keep
you alive for days,
so giving you an opportunity to be
rescued.
You never would have had in the North
Atlantic for example,
where you'd be dead in an hour or two
from the hypothermia,
but it also gives you time to go through
what stand in just described.
As I said,
multiple disaster movies all wrapped
into one.
Now as the hours drag on,
Stanton says that the delirium starts to
set in and again,
the Indianapolis survivors' are going
through all of these movie tropes that
forever the movies will wrench drama and
emotion and you know,
your sense of feeling for the people.
The fake people in these movies are
stories in the Indianapolis.
People are going through it for real.
Their ship went down,
remember it like 12,
15:00
AM first thing in the morning,
but in the middle of the night on
Monday,
Stanton writes that by Wednesday the men
start attacking one another.
They think they're seeing enemies and at
one point he writes in an a and he says
in within 10 minutes an estimated 50
boys were killed by their compatriots
when everybody snapped at once.
So we have another movie here too.
It's like the shipwreck movie.
So it's another kind of disaster film.
You know,
people are stuck in rafts and dealing
with sharks and going crazy.
Not having.
I mean it says though,
we tried to figure out how many things
you could hit the same people with
before they broke
the higher human qualities that are
visible throughout.
I mean the,
the part that got me was as,
as people start dying more and more,
they need their lifevest because the
life vests are failing.
They're not meant to be in the water
that long.
So you have these stories about people
that will,
you know,
go over and make sure someone that they
think is dead has actually expired and
then take their life vest off.
But the one guy that stanton was quoting
in the story,
he just,
he would not let them go without some
sort of a prayer.
He'd hold them close,
which you know,
these guys are exhausted by this time.
So anything more than the most minimum
effort is excruciating.
And he was going to see that each one of
these people had a prayer set over them
before he let them go and you know,
to be eaten by the sharks.
I mean those are the little touches in a
story like this that break your heart
because those are the.
That's what separates us from just being
some mindless thing that's torn apart by
the sharks.
I mean the thinking that goes into all
of the.
I mean,
that man survived the one that said the
prayers over the people he had to
unstrap from the lifevest.
What are you thinking about at night the
rest of your life?
They will eventually be rescued by a
pilot that they're not looking for
anybody.
The pilot just kind of sees these people
in the water
and he,
Stan Lowe and he can see the sharks
attacking them.
Stanton rights of a guy named Lieutenant
Adrian marks who's,
um,
you know,
one of the early people on the scene
once they figure out they've got people
in the water and it's interesting
because of the secrecy involved in this.
They don't know who these people are.
It's not like they're going,
we found the Indianapolis crew.
One of the first questions they're gonna
ask when they pick the first person up
is who the hell are you and where you're
from.
So a stanton writes,
quote,
Lieutenant Adrian marks reached the
scene of the survivors at 3:20
PM.
And what he found astounded him,
Lieutenant Atterbury informed marks that
there were a great many people scattered
over a wide area.
He said not to drop any lifesaving
equipment until he made a full tour,
which marks quickly did both pilots then
decided to steer away from the people
clinging to the rafts and to concentrate
on those,
held up solely by vests.
Thirty minutes after he arrived,
marks began bombing the boys with his
provisions.
About the same time the destroyers,
Ralph Talbot and Madison received orders
to cut short their patrols near the
island of a leafy and head directly to
the rescue site.
Their ETA 12 hours from the present
sometime early Friday morning marks knew
the situation was dire from his recon
altitude of a mere 25 feet.
He had a clear view of the deep green.
See in the hundreds of sharks circling
the men night,
which he knew was the sharks.
Normal feeding period was approaching
one of Mark's,
his crew and watched as a shark attack
one of the men and dragged him under.
As Marx himself witnessed more attacks.
His anxiety grew.
It looked to him as if the survivors
were so weak,
they couldn't even begin to fight back
and quote,
and then there's a footnote,
stanton and put in that says,
the sharks had in fact remained a
constant presence throughout the men's
ordeal.
Even during the daylight hours,
not long after Gwynn who was the first
pilot
to find the people in the water.
By the way,
not long after Gwyn showed up,
a massive shark attack involving an
estimated 30 fish head in about 15
minutes,
taken some 60 boys perched on a floater
net.
And to quote that doesn't begin to even
do justice to the parts of the story
that seem by comparison with crap like
that to be nothing.
I mean,
how do you talk about no water and how
that makes you feel day after day when
you're suffering and no decent food.
I mean,
these no sleep,
the wounds.
I mean,
they said that one boy and one of these
rafts,
one of the survivors couldn't help but
point out with sitting there with his
mouth wide open in such pain that he
couldn't even make a noise.
Um,
you ever been in a situation with a
person like that?
Just one person in one situation,
any one of these things is,
you know,
again,
when you talk about war,
the first thing you think about is none
of this stuff should ever happen again.
And then the next thing you think about
is that when it does look what people
can endure and look at what they do in
terms of self sacrifice for another
human being who's in a situation,
you know,
that's awful in a situation that you
yourself might be sharing.
So that's when it becomes extra heroic
when some of these people are doing
things like giving their life vest to a
guy who needs it more.
It's not like you're doing a good deed
for someone you found on the street.
It's,
it's reducing your own chances of
survival to help somebody else's chances
of survival.
Those are pretty amazing stories and I
think the reason that we're so
fascinated with these horrible tales is
there's something life affirming about
the people that get through them and not
just how they conducted themselves at
the time,
but how it both changed them and how,
you know,
the,
the silent heroism of living with it
afterwards and I think we have more
understanding of that now than we used
to with things like ptsd,
but I don't think we even give it
anywhere near the thought it deserves.
I mean,
we all have traumatic memories in our
lives.
Life provide you with some by default,
but some people get way more than their
share.
Can you imagine if like plugging
something in the back of your head,
like from the Matrix,
I could upload the memories of one of
these Indianapolis survivors' into your,
not just your brain,
but like have it fused with your
emotions so you know you have the
feelings.
You could have the flashbacks from an
experience you never had.
Imagine what that would do to you pretty
darn quickly,
right?
I just gave you the memories of an
Indianapolis survivor.
Now,
imagine not being able to ever get them
out of your head.
Now imagine going through the original
experience.
You know,
my brain never wants to ever do any
research on this personally.
You understand,
but I can't help but wonder if somehow
the cumulative effect over decades of
all these horrible memories and
flashbacks and nightmares,
does that ever come to equaling the
terribleness of the experience itself
and if it doesn't,
how much of it is like,
you know,
picking at the scab continually,
of the wound that changed your life
forever.
Now we may not have gone through the
wound,
but think about how upset you'd be just
having the memories all of a sudden the
implanted in your head about what it was
like when you got it mentally or
emotionally speaking.
In my mind when you look at it,
the sinking of the Indianapolis is not
really a war story.
If it was a war story,
I think maybe we would have included it
in the series that we're doing on the
Pacific war and the war in Asia in the
Second World War right now,
but it's not like that in my mind.
It's about as connected to war as I see
it as the nine slash 11 attacks were
connected to terrorism.
They are the thing that creates,
you know,
the first domino falling in a number of
horrible incidents.
But once the initial attacks happen,
you go from having a war movie,
if you'll pardon the connection again to
entertainment to a disaster film,
you know,
like the kind I grew up with and as I
said,
what is.
So I don't know if amazing is a good
word to use in such a horrific
situation.
What is so frightful about what the
Indianapolis survivors' and non
survivors had to go through is they
don't get to just have one disaster film
be,
you know,
they're traumatic memory.
They get to walk out on one of these,
you know,
movies like,
the towering inferno and get right on,
you know,
the Poseidon and then they get to
experience the poseidon adventure as one
right after another.
It is as though,
you know,
the great gods of history,
we're trying to see exactly how much
they could pile on the same group of
human beings and since we're going to do
a study here,
why not have hundreds of people in your
sample size and see how much they can
take and what happens to them,
you know,
as you continue to give them as much
material as some of the people we pity
them most for going through terrible
human experiences.
What several of them put together,
experienced.
That's why for me,
if you're talking about,
you know,
terrible places in human history to have
found yourself in or if your time
machine happens to go awry and you hit
the button wrong and you end up in just
about the worst place you could.
For me,
that would be anywhere from about July
30th to August,
second,
19,
45,
a couple hundred miles from the nearest
land in the Philippines sea,
and I would definitely say if that
happened to you,
you would have found yourself for that
particular time and place in the worst
place in the world.
Audible has the largest selection of
audio books on the planet.
What more do you need to know?
Really than that,
when audible started sponsoring our
programs,
they were in a similar situation to
where if somebody said,
well you do.
I said a podcaster and then had to
explain that for a long time.
Well,
once upon a time,
audio books were something that people
had to have explained to them.
Now everybody understands audio books
and so everyone understands audible,
the leading provider and.
Well,
to give you an idea of selection,
if you're ever worried about that sort
of thing.
They have multiple books and I mean I
stopped counting at like five on the USS
Indianapolis sinking,
so let's just call it an unmatched
selection and if the story you just
heard acts as an appetizer towards
finding out more and there's a lot more
audibles got plenty to choose from.
In fact,
they actually have the book we quoted
from Stanton's book in harm's way,
which I've read in is incredible,
but there's a bunch of other ones too.
If you read that or heard this story,
uh,
you can get granular.
I mean,
um,
there's a new book that just came out on
the Indianapolis,
so you want some more information on
this.
You want to have somebody speak to you
for a little bit longer than this one
lasted.
Well,
why don't you go to audible,
sign up for their free trial,
offer audible.com
forward slash Carlin.
Text my name,
do five,
zero,
zero five,
zero to get started.
And you can download one,
two,
three.
I think I stopped counting at four or
five books that they have on the sinking
of the USS Indianapolis.
It's just one of those stories that it's
so hard to believe that it's true,
and as I said,
you know,
there's almost this vicarious horror
movie fascination with it,
and then it just breaks your heart to
actually think that no,
this is real stuff and the basic
information you're getting comes from
the mouths of the people who were
experiencing this,
but that's what makes history so
compelling.
At least two people who have whatever it
is,
the gene or just a sense of the dramatic
and there's a reason that this story
continues to both fascinated but also
inspire.
Why don't you go to audible,
check out what they have available.
As I said,
audible.com
forward slash Carlin gets you into the
free 30 day trial and then you can start
to see what it's all about.
I mean,
I've talked about every angle that
audible has in terms of advantages.
In the old days,
these were the things that were new and
unusual.
Now you just sort of expect this sort of
stuff from your audio book provider
because audible's the one that came up
with all this stuff and made this the
standard.
You want to own your books.
Audible,
let you own your books.
I mean,
it's stuff like that that has made me
happy to tell you about them all this
time.
I mean,
as I said,
you want a little bit more USS
Indianapolis Info.
Go to audible.com
forward slash Carla and signup for a
free 30 day.
Offered a day.
Own the books you get and started
experiencing all the little things that
audible just does.
Write about audio books.
Be sure to follow us on twitter.
The address is at hardcore history.
Hey,
a buck a show.
That's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.